[Music]
i teach at one of the best schools ever
and my joy and my passion for teaching
art is just waning
where are you finding joy in other
places in your life i don't
that's probably a lot of the problem
[Music]
blame it all on my route
i showed up in boots
ruined your james listen this weekend
so you know my son's like all obsessed
with 90s country this weekend the one
and only dude garth brooks came to town
and if like a few months ago my son was
like hey dad listen
have you ever heard of garth brooks and
i was like
no son tell me more anyway we went
dude
i had these visions of our first concert
together being like metallic or
something dramatic
and it was garth brooks and dude he's
saying his little 12 year old heart out
and i did too
and man we hugged we danced it was the
best father-son event way to go garth
and by the way welcome to the john
delony show dude good to see everybody i
kind of got carried away a little bit
james was so fun
i've heard that even if you're not a
country fan that he puts on the best
show that people have ever seen it's so
frustrating how good it is it's so
frustrating and i'd like to say
john and james which should be a new
hashtag is that how those work
um there was a he's got two guitarists
he's got a fender player and
a gibson player
and together they created magic so like
a guy that can really play and then a
guy that just plays power chords exactly
and runs around and goes
i see what you did there that hurt my
feelings hey welcome to the show if you
want to be a part of the madness
give me a call at
one it's 1-844-693-3291 eight four four
six nine three three two nine one and we
talk about mental health relationships
your marriage what's going on should you
get married what's going on in schools
these days anything you wanna talk about
give us a call and you can go to
johndaloney.com
ask ask fill out the form and we would
love to have you on the show let's go to
kelly in oklahoma city oklahoma what's
up kelly
hey how are you we're just rocking onto
the breaking dawn how are you
good oh you're in oklahoma that's like
that's the home of garth right it it is
in the awesome he just kind of pulls the
whole world together
have you seen him play
no i don't like concerts
listen kelly listen
i don't even know what your question is
going to how we're going to end up with
this thing but one of the things i'm
going to tell you to do is make sure you
catch it when it comes to town it's fun
how can i help
well i am an art teacher here in
oklahoma city i teach at one of the best
schools ever i have one of one of the
best principals ever
and my joy and my passion
for teaching art is just waning
it's
so confusing for me because this is i've
i've been teaching for about 14 years so
i was pretty late to the game
but i
i love the kids i love seeing the
creativity
light come on above their heads and
and i just can barely stand it anymore
and i i just i don't know what's
happening
um
where are you finding joy in other
places in your life
well
i don't
that's probably a lot of the problem so
tell me what's been going on in the last
few years
in other parts of my life yes yes
um
i have a sister
a couple years older than me with
full-on dementia now oh man
i've got a husband that works
all the time yeah
and my son is 21 halfway through college
and he's
kind of um
out the door as well
so i think i've i've really put a lot
into my teaching and
with the pandemic and
just
just with my facebook friends around the
world my facebook art teacher friends
they're all feeling this burnout
it's worldwide and
the kids are totally different i don't
know how to help them i don't know what
to do um
it's like we just need to start a new
find a new starting point yeah
man you're just you're putting such
great
beauty you're putting beautiful words to
the hurt
and so thank you so much for your call
um
so when we when this call airs i want
you to go back and listen to it and
listen to how you talk about art
teaching your students the kids their
creativity your whole voice is different
and then when i asked you about the last
few years
um
your voice changes in rather dramatic
fashion okay
one of the things
the data is telling us is that a bunch
of people have been changing jobs
and that most people who've changed jobs
i think the last one i saw 75 of them
wish they had to change jobs
and what that tells me there's a hundred
different reasons for that but what that
tells me is that over the last 10 15
years we have found increasingly
unskilled in our life
we don't know how to deal with our
teenage kids we don't know how to deal
with the transitioning marriage what
that even looks like we don't know how
to date anymore we don't
we've lost the ability to be successful
in these normal our faith's all screwed
up church is a bust i mean we've just
got all these areas where we're
struggling
but we were good at work
we were good at our craft at the thing
we did
and so over the last 10 15 25 years
we've dumped everything into that world
and that's where we found our purpose
and our joy and our connectivity
and then over the last 24 months it got
taken away from us
and we had to deal with what was in the
uh what we thought was in the rearview
mirror but was actually in our back seat
which is
my husband works all the time and my 21
year old kid like my identity was a mom
and now who am i now that my kid's 21
and he can buy beer for himself and
that's weird right all those things
especially for creatives who are
teaching that becomes such a difficult
transition
to look back and go oh man
i don't i i didn't hear in your voice
that you're sick of teaching i hear in
your voice that you're
exhausted by life
tell me i'm wrong and i'm happy to be
wrong here
there is times when when it's like it's
run its course it's been 15 years i need
to go
express my creative self and my
professional self differently that's
great i didn't hear that i hear somebody
who is just looking around at her life
saying is this what this is going to be
yeah well i do teach 550 littles a week
so that's a lot a lot in a public school
that's kind of how it rolls yeah totally
see every student and um
where do you where do you go where do
you go for restoration
i sit on my couch and i watch tv
i just veg out
if i'm not teaching yeah
um
tell me about your relationship with
your husband
um
i know he works a lot is he is he
a lot i see this a lot with men too
they're not successful at home
they feel a gap with their spouse and
they don't know how to bridge it they
don't know what they're doing wrong
they don't know what to do with the with
transitioning adult kids they don't know
what to do with newborns either
but they're really good at being an
architect or they're really good at
being a lawyer and that ends up being
where they spend most of their time
you know what i mean
right and he he jumped from the
corporate world
in and fell in love with teaching so
he's teaching at university now
okay and he is just in love with it and
i can i tell you
there's nothing greater than having 30
or 60 or 120 college students think that
you're great
you know what i mean
it feels good right
yes and it's different than a bunch of
second graders saying can i go to the
bathroom i peed you know what i mean
it's so different but their hugs are
pretty awesome
those hugs come from the devs they're so
great so here would be my recommendation
um
i would love to see a couple things
number one
i'd love to see you get a couple of art
teachers in or music teachers
um here's the other thing you found your
profession on the margins the last 15
years so you're not just doing the
creative work you're having to fight for
its existence and that's exhausting
it's especially exhausting because it's
insane
you know what i mean when you're when
you're fighting for a dating like you're
dating somebody and you're fighting for
the relationship and you know that guy
kind of sucks
it's different because you're fighting
for it but your body knows like
but when you find yourself farting i
mean farting that's kind of funny when
you find yourself fighting
for
um
art
like the value of art and children and
teaching them play and creativity and
how to
like do drafts and how to do a first
draft and a second draft and a third
draft and come up with something
powerful and work hard when you find
yourself trying to explain why that's
more important than doing a driller kill
worksheet on some you know what i mean
it's magical right that's exactly right
yeah you've got to defend yourself on
every level as an art teacher so absurd
so here's what i'd love to do i'd love
for you to get three or four
women in your world who are also
teachers
and
you know as well as i do because i've
been a public school teacher with a
giant at a giant giant school
that a lot of times teachers get
together and then we complain and we
complain and we complain about the
parents and the students and can you
believe that right and what i would love
for you all to do is something different
than complaining i'd love you all to get
together and go get
chips and salsa or something and jess or
get coffee or whatever it is
and i want y'all to grieve
i want y'all to even if you have to
write it down or y'all can doodle like
and draw if you're art teachers i want
y'all to talk about
together what used to be
and what we still love about this thing
and what's not and that it just is hard
because in the
the plowed fields of grief you can look
around and there's no green there's no
trees there's no fruit
but that's where the soil gets ready for
what comes next and out of that grief is
where the okay so how are we going to
turn this thing and reach these kids
because what we were doing is different
now
and i'd love for you to sit with your
husband and say hey we both work a lot
and i miss you
and
we've got 40 years left of this thing
let's make them as fun and reckless and
silly and joy-filled and
intimacy filled as we possibly can and
that means we're gonna have to
completely clear the deck and do
something different
and
ugh have you written your sister that
letter yet
have i what i'm sorry
written your sister that letter
oh
no
you need to
he
the one where you tell her i love you
and i miss you and i hate having to take
care of you and i had a picture of what
our life was going to be like as we got
old together and it's going to be
different
yeah
you need to write that down and read it
to her
and i'll be one of the hardest things
you've ever done
but here's what we're doing
most of us at the end of the last three
years which is on the back end of the
last 15 years
we have to sit down and be exhausted and
we have to sit down and grieve what was
agree what was because it's been hard
and we've just been moving and running
so fast
that we have our bodies are like whoa
whoa
we've missed a lot we've missed a lot
we've missed a lot call your son tell
him you miss him
whatever those hard things do you miss
him
yes yes do you tell him
sure good yeah
so all these things i'm saying what do
you think you were hoping i would just
say yeah get a new job
i know
or or go part-time or something
yeah hey listen if you want to go
part-time go part-time
yeah like don't don't lose a second to
sleep about it my fear is just and again
i'm basing this just off the tone of
your voice is if you went part-time you
would take away the last shining light
you've got in your in your life
it may give you a ton of space to
breathe again but if that space is just
going to be used up on the couch
watching tv then god help you don't do
that
i'd love to see you get home and before
you sat down on the couch i'd love to
see you take that exhausted
tapped out body and go for a walk
and listen to an audio book or a podcast
i'd love for you to
call a friend and use one of those
headsets so you don't have to hold your
phone up to your ear and you can just go
for a walk and pump your arms mom style
down the down the down the road
and just say hey how are you to a friend
who does something totally different
and not just come home and pop down on
the couch
[Music]
and it's time to go it's time to go it's
cool i'm cool that i don't think you're
there yet i want you to look at your
world and say hey i'm worth more than
this
and god help us i'm so grateful for you
thank you thank you thank you kelly
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month better online therapy wants
to remind you that you are important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john dolone show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 percent off
that's betterhelp.com
all right we're back
um
yeah james in that last segment
you ever been farting
what did you say kelly everybody was
kung fu farting yeah that's the time i'm
going to sing it from now on over all
for sure sing it what was i even saying
fighting
you're talking about art so that's where
it came out like
fighting fighting for art
fighting for art otherwise known as
farting and let's go to diane in
milwaukee what's up diane
hi how are you so much for taking my
call i'm i'm well thank you how are you
so glad you're called i'm good i'm good
so what's up how can i help
um
okay so i'm calling i this seems like a
minor issue compared to so many of your
callers but hopefully it'll help hold on
hold on hold on
no comparing what's going on promise
okay
yes
are you are you struggling through stuff
right now
uh yeah a little bit okay no that's why
i'm calling it that's my colleague don't
minimize it okay i'm so glad you called
i'm no i don't even fully understand why
you're calling but i'm so glad that you
called cool
okay yeah okay cool i got a little bit
on my screen here but i'm gonna let you
tell me the full story so go for it yeah
all right so um about
almost four weeks ago uh my husband and
i welcomed our wonderful baby boy into
the world awesome number one is it cool
baby number one
this is baby number one yes welcome
welcome to the adventure it's so cool
all right yes it's crazy and cool and
wonderful um
but at the hospital um like everything
went really well with the birth um very
non-traumatic as far as births go
sounds great
hold on timeout
as far as i don't mean to keep
interrupting you but as far as births go
as this massive drama happens
you are the best minimizer ever okay go
ahead
okay um
so after he was born we arrived in the
hospital you know overnight and he lost
too much weight basically over the
course of our stay so we had to
supplement with formula okay um
and i also i was told to see specialists
about breastfeeding and see what's going
on
and it turns out that i have something
called insufficient glandular tissue
which basically just means that i'm
never at least with him going to be able
to produce enough milk for him to
survive off of me
so he's just going to have to be
supplement formula and that was
something that i just i did not expect
at all and um like beforehand a lot of
women had told me like oh rest being so
hard but
if you stick with it you know if you
don't give up
um if you're not you know if you don't
just
throw in the towel it'll get better and
it'll be the most wonderful thing you've
ever had
experience kind of thing
so i didn't really anticipate just not
being able to
um
and
it was really hard the first couple
weeks especially just like every single
time he needed to eat it was like
i'm not enough for him and
like
yeah it's still
when i talk about it apparently
um it makes me just feel like i'm a
deficient mother and
wife you know like both of
both my husband and son deserve
something better than i can give them
and
i don't know how to i feel like mentally
i've written myself a letter and told
myself it's not my fault
um
but
it still doesn't take away the fact that
i i can't do something that i really
want to do and um
i feel and i'm worried too that like i
know in the future there's going to be
things with my son that i want to do for
him that i can't do for him so
i just don't want to feel this way the
rest of my life
so i'm kind of wondering how to how to
handle this
wow
thanks for
man the number of folks who experience
this is is
in the bajillions and so thank you for
having the courage to call
um
because this is a call that's for all of
us who are parents right and you just
said it so eloquently there's things we
want to provide for our kid
that we're gonna run up against those
boundaries in our lives and
how do we
how do we deal with that so
where where
where did this picture come from that
that
a good mother that my husband and child
deserve equals
these set of variables where does that
picture come from
you said other women have told you this
yeah um like women in my community um
who are moms um
i've just heard women kind of judging
other women for
using formula you know and it's kind of
like an implicit thing
that like if you
if you really are willing to put an
effort to be you know give your child
the best then you'll breastfeed
exclusively kind of thing um
and i know my mom my mom breastfed all
of us and she was i don't remember her
being particularly judgey about other
women but
um it was just something i kind of
expected to be able to do myself
what is
like what's a big regret you've had in
your life
just in the past sometime it could be
when you were seven and you didn't make
the team or when you were 14 and like
what's the regret you have
uh
i feel like i've
i've kind of
dealt with every disappointment and felt
like my life has turned out pretty great
and
so i don't really regret
anything that might have happened that i
didn't like at the time
so um where where here's where i was
going with that
there is an entire ecosystem
designed
to a t
with a thousand points of entry
a hundred thousand points of entry
it's a war zone for mothers
no matter what you do you will feel
guilty
because that's how we get you to buy
stuff and click on stuff
you're not enough you're using the wrong
this why are you putting them in those
clothes and you can put them in that
clothes oh my gosh can you believe
mothers whatever it's an entire
oxygen like it's it's an ecosystem with
its own air its own water and it's
insane
and
what the heartbreaking part of this for
me is somehow
not somehow it's very very intentionally
that you found yourself in this
ecosystem
and are unable to see
how blessed and fortunate your son is to
have you as his mom
and how wildly out of all the crazy
women he could have picked your husband
picked you and won the lottery
yeah that's what he said
yeah and
he's probably not an idiot so
he's not gonna lie to you
and if he didn't believe that he would
just say nothing right
because he's a good guy he actually
believes that
and somehow a picture got put in your
head that this is the only way forward
and it sounds like the picture came from
gossipy
whiny
judgy people who are trying to prop up
their own lack of what in the crap am i
doing as a new mom they're trying to
prop that up by
spitting on other women
and so my suggestion to you is to opt
out of the entire system
here's what i mean by that
they
don't get a vote
and the way around
people don't get a vote you wrote
yourself a letter that said it's okay
i would love for you to write another
letter and write yourself dear diane
here's why i'm an incredible mother
because in writing yourself a letter
like it's not my fault
the focus of that letter was on the
deficiency and i want you to shift the
whole boat here towards gratitude and
thank god we live in an era when science
can swoop in and say hey you've got a
particular thing here and we got you and
we can all cheer and high-five each
other
you know what i mean
yeah
and hey i've got a husband who in the
1400s might have had me beheaded and now
he loves it right he loves it like
whatever
and and and all that to say is
man there's such a big picture here and
i hate the fact that you oh like
millions of other women have been
dragged into this cesspool of oh yeah oh
yeah
cause it's because you're so much more
than that
here's the here's the honest to god ugly
truth
you're going to have to practice your
way out of this on a daily basis which
means you're going to have to grieve
i wanted to be able to have these
moments with my kid and i'm not going to
and i'm not going to hate on other moms
who get to have this experience it's
cool
the same way as when you're older and
maybe your kid is going to be five six
and you're gonna have a friend whose kid
is six eight and she gets to sit on the
front row at varsity basketball games
and you're not
and you could say i really wish i had
that experience but i'm gonna go to my
kids art exhibit and right so it's okay
to call those out in fact i think you
have to call those out parents are like
no it's cool it's the same it's not it's
different
i wanted it to be like this and it's
like this that's great
it's okay but you gotta acknowledge it
and then
you have to practice
you don't get a vote
you don't get space in my head you don't
get space in my heart and god help you
you don't get between me and my baby
and i'm a huge proponent on
whether you're breastfeeding or whether
you are
um
bottle feeding
skin and skin contact the skin is skin
contact so still make that happen
okay
and connect yourself with that kid you
don't have to check out of the whole
process just because
um
your body doesn't produce enough milk in
this season you see what i'm saying
yeah
the person you've got to be graceful
with is is you
yeah
you know i mean you are judging yourself
like those other women and i want you to
give diane a break
yeah
i see what you read i also want you to
be really when's your next checkup
um
later this week okay
will you make me say i promise
i promise
i'm so suckering you into this you don't
have to actually do this but here's what
i would like you to do
i would like you to tell your
um the nurse practitioner or the ob gyn
when you check in
if you're still waking up and this is
the first thought on your mind
and you continue to have words like i'm
a failure i'm a quitter
i didn't try hard enough
i want you to let your um doctor know
that you're struggling okay
okay
the postpartum weight of some of these
thoughts is heavier than they should be
and i i don't know you well enough to do
any sort of diagnostic on that and in
fact i don't even i don't even know i
could diagnose somebody with um
postpartum that's just not my expertise
but i do know week four week five week
seven week eight those
thoughts of
why in the world did this beautiful baby
get stuck with a crappy mom like me
i know those thoughts
are coming from a different place and
sometimes getting a little extra support
is really is a game changer for for new
moms okay
yeah
last thing can you give me one more
thing
sure i want you to do this just for two
weeks okay just do this for two weeks
and if it works keep doing it if it
doesn't you can just be like that
podcaster's a [ __ ]
um i want you to tell your husband
um can we not say anything
and can we just sit by each other on the
couch and hold hands
okay okay as simple as that if you want
to be really pervy about it you can take
your socks off and y'all can touch feet
too
okay all right what i want your body to
do is i want it to reconnect itself with
your husband
there's a lot of tiny little gaps that
emerge in this season
some of which are imagined some of which
are very very real
and all couples with a new kid they have
to set aside time
to a lot of it is hey when can we get
back to sex when coming back to sex and
going back to sex that's all fine that's
a different conversation i want people
to reconnect right away and a lot of the
reconnection is look at the baby look at
the baby look at the baby
and
the relationship ends up
sideways or it gets put in a drawer in
the back of the closet because we've got
other stuff to do and i want you to take
20 minutes 30 minutes just watch a show
tell them that some guy told you you got
to watch a show together i want you to
hold hands and touch feet while you're
doing it no making out no
just just connect and drop your
shoulders okay what will happen
hopefully is in a couple of weeks when
he says
i cannot believe how fortunate and
blessed i am to have you as the mother
of my baby
your body will receive it it won't
reject it out of hand is that fair
yeah and i'm sure he'll be up for that
i listen
he's a good guy
he's a great guy you can tell him right
now you got a window use it wisely
you could tell him you know what i
really we need to re-roof the house and
he's like i got it i got it
this is a season when husbands feel so
incredibly useless
and any sort of way they feel like
they're helping is
they're
yes they're all in unless they're idiots
and then they're like no bro go to go to
work and hang out with my buddies and
then that's a whole other phone call on
this show listen diane
yes your baby won the lottery
hey i i give bad advice sometimes i give
i don't ever lie
your baby won the lottery with you
and i'm so grateful that that little boy
gets to grow up with you as his mama for
his entire
life
that kid won life
and it's just beginning we'll be right
back
hey dr john dolone here let's talk about
sleep my friends it's one of the best
things you can do to improve your mental
health and your physical health in one
of the biggest areas we neglect it's
time to change that and for me getting
good deep restorative sleep starts with
a good mattress that's why my family
sleeps on dream cloud mattresses right
now dream cloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for our listeners
499 bucks and accessories plus an
additional 250 cash discount that's like
704
in accessories and savings pillows
mattress protector luxury sheets all of
it it's time to get the rest your body
and mind needs because your mental
health matters
this means prioritize your sleep it
means get seven to nine hours of sleep
each night that means ditching the 10
year old hand-me-down mattress that you
got from your weird aunt a long time ago
go to
dreamcloudsleep.com deloney or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress and
enjoy your savings and start sleeping
today
all right we are back hey actually we
already got four emails from moms who
have some opinions um for her
oh over the
this episode's not even out yet we're
not even done recording but we already
got some feedback on that i i guarantee
you one of them was like uh
um if you just use uh thieves essential
oil and
have you tried the keto diet yet so good
you should be vegan it was super helps
with lactate products
oh gosh listen
moms
you'll all know y'all all know how hard
this is
be kind to one another
husbands shut your mouths well like
moms be nice to each other
be kind
so hard
we already got two more emails didn't we
all right i can hear it going ding ding
ding ding ding ding
let's go to robert in san diego what's
up roberto
hey
i
have a dilemma for
in my mind
hey
all right let's let's go into the mind
of roberto and see what's up
hi so i am a blue collar worker i uh we
in my industry we travel
ninety percent of the time what do you
do for life
real railroader okay
how long you how long you been in
i just started six months ago
roughly okay
and um
so when we uh when i started working out
here and they told me that our divorce
rate is
extremely high that's right
higher than normal
and
right now i'm with a lady i've been with
her for a little bit over a year
and
i love her i want to marry her she's
expressed to me she wants to marry me
the thing that bothers me though
is that divorce rate
i've gone out to look at rings i've i
mean i want to get something for i want
to start a family of something with her
but i don't want to be part of
statistics and
it hurts brother i cannot man you're a
hero to me today
for real and i don't say that lightly
thank you for calling
the
man you're a hard worker
uh i've got somebody i love um he's a
wise
friend and mentor for me and he has been
in the in the railroad for a long time
and so um
jenna let me know that we're gonna have
a call about a railroad uh on today's
show so i reached out to him
and um i said hey
let me back up for you guys who don't
know the life of someone who works on
the railroad
is
absolute
unfathomable hell
everything from the way they do when you
find out when you're working to what
you're working to how you're working
it's an absolute chaotic
mess
your family never know it's just a zoo
and you've been there for what six
months and you've experienced this right
oh yeah it's like so much so that uh
several railroads give the spouse a full
pension upon retirement is yours do that
yes that's a railroad retirement so
think about how bad it is
and how much how sucky a job it is that
they say if somebody will stick it out
with you this whole time we'll pay them
too that's how bad it is
and
man i wouldn't have believed it had i
not have i not seen it up close
it's unbelievable that a group of people
decide to run a business like that um
it's just madness madness but
uh i reached out to him and here's what
he told me okay
i'm gonna tell you um
i'm gonna
actually he sent me some text messages
so i'm gonna just read them directly to
you is that cool
okay
all right now also understand this guy
runs the railroad uh in
the south and so he's got some other
opinions too is that cool i'm gonna read
it here's what he wrote number one get
out of cali
number two
go to a yard job with a schedule if your
seniority allows and base your budgets
on yard wages
getting out of cali to somewhere with
the lower cost of living will help have
you been able to roll off to yard yet
are they just putting you all on
trains
it's my type of work's not necessarily
working on the trains okay
but
i haven't had the opportunity to get a
yard drawback still okay still working
on that
i know seniority like yeah so for those
of you don't know you could have put in
your vacation two years ago for
christmas to be with your
spouse who's coming home from overseas
deployment
and somebody with uh uh five months more
seniority than you can just bump you
they just take it from you and you just
gotta get back in and go and nobody
cares right so seniority yeah i just
keep bumping you off the jobs that will
help your family
um
here's number three and this is the hard
one
he wrote i'm assuming you're young if
you have less than 10 years seniority or
more than 20 years to retirement start
looking for an exit strategy and do
something else
and i know that one's hard to hear
because the pay of the railroad can be
really good and enticing right
yeah
and
it's it's designed not it's designed to
keep families apart which is why they
pay your wife off at the end
here's another thought though this
person that gave me this wisdom is also
married happily got a great wife got a
bunch of kids and they figured out and
make it work
um
when you're on the road
you got to stay out of the bars
when you're on the road
when you get home go home
don't run around with women at the
terminals don't get caught on when
you're getting laid off i mean late up
and you're having to do your eight-hour
rest at some community and it's so easy
just to run across the street to
you gotta have enough strength and
fortitude to stay in your hotel room go
to bed
so we can blame the job all day long
what i know is there's a lot of divorce
in a lot of different jobs police
officers there's a lot of jobs are hard
um and you've got to make some choices
i'm not going to cheat on my wife i when
i'm home i'm gonna be so fully home
and she needs to know what she's signing
up for
based on what i've seen his wisdom to
um if you can do something else if you
can make good money um
working hard somewhere where you find
value and joy go for it my friend kevin
is the ceo of a yardscape company dude
and
they take care of those guys college
they take care of a lot of stuff for
those folks and their kids
and those guys work real hard they're
blue collar guys and they work their
butts off and they go to bed tired every
night but that it's more conducive to
families and mechanics that i know have
great family life right you know what
i'm saying so there's there's there's
hard-working
like steel slinging jobs out there that
aren't railroad jobs
when i say
he recommends you doing something else
what's the first thought in your mind
honestly i came from working blue collar
and the construction trades and
everything
and
i i haven't found
a job that that pays as well that's
right compared to out here
and i i was
i was swinging a hammer yeah i was
telling my
timing my tongue with a hammer yeah yeah
prior to this and it's difficult because
my whole career has been around working
with trains now with
a train company and that specialist type
of work and
i mean that's one of the first things
that was told when i
started the railroad hey what's uh
what's a good uh
what's a good tip you'll give one of us
this new guy please
that was the first time they told us
wait say that one more time
one night well nice for the railroader
one one of the old
old heads
what's a good tip that they would give
us to succeed working for the railroad
and what he told me was
leave
was he messing with you
no
so here's what i'll tell you and i'll
tell every i've told my work team here
the day my wife comes to me and says we
can't do this i can't do this life
anymore
is the day i'm out
because she's more important than this
when i've worked at um there's a
university or two i worked at when she
came and said you're not okay you're not
well
this is hurting us a left
because i made a choice that she was
more important than this
and if you're ready to make that choice
then that choice will
be what it is and it might mean i got to
look at living somewhere else in the
country to get a job where i'm not
throwing a hammer
and there's no water and it's hot right
or it's san diego's most beautiful place
in the country but it's also really
really really expensive
um
is there another place i can go and get
a different like whatever that looks
like
if she's right she'll be worth it
and if she's not that's okay man that
still be okay i heard you talk about her
though in a way that sounds like
you've put a period at the end of that
sentence she's she's she's it for you
right you've chosen her
yeah okay
so here's what i want you to be real
careful of when we get in these moments
right now we've got quote unquote hard
decisions to make we tend to back
ourselves into a corner and make it an
either or and it's an either or right
now
or else
i want to really caution you on that
okay you can get engaged tomorrow
get married the following day
and run the railroads for the next two
years until y'all figure out what comes
next
she may settle in and love the space
love that you're gone all the time and
be able to
work she may be an attorney and wants to
do her way this is not a have to do this
right now
i still think you can carry on your
romance i still think you can continue
showing up at the yard every day and get
on train and do what you need to do and
begin to look at what other jobs exist
out there that can pay well but also let
me have a family and a home and to
everybody who is in management at a
railroad company stop
you will make more money if your people
have families and are able to enjoy
their lives
they will stick around they will work
harder
it's unbelievable
how terrible they treat y'all
blows my mind
but listen to me very carefully robert
you're worth more than what they're
gonna offer you right now okay
you just aren't you just are i've never
met a single
person who works the road who's been
there for any length of time that says
no dude this is the greatest thing ever
you should for sure stay
never not one not one
i've spoken with young people who just
got back from uh fallujah from overseas
being deployed and they're like dude i'd
sign up again tomorrow
and people were shooting at them
when it comes to this though what you're
what the old heads in the in the yard
told you that's a hundred percent what i
hear every time
is get out while you're young and go do
something else and what i'll tell you is
the money over time won't be worth it so
what about this what if you did it for
two years and saved every stinking penny
lived spartan live
so cheap save every penny and let that
be a launching off pad for you when you
all move to kansas you all move to texas
or you move to new mexico or arizona or
something where the cost of living is a
quarter of how much it cost or half of
what it cost
and then you and your wife can start
your life
together
and man i'm not worried about you
getting divorced because you're already
planning way ahead of the game
i'm not worried about you because you're
you are thinking it through you're being
intentional and that is wisdom my man
i'm proud of you we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life
the single 30 year old looking to
sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone
and this book isn't me talking at you
this book is me walking with you because
i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right we are back and it's time for
our second installment of everybody's
favorite segment
facts are your friends where we have
simple conversations about complex ideas
is this everybody's favorite segment i'm
going with that i'm
in the greatest segment ever produced
ever i don't know that that thing jay
leno used to do on the street was pretty
funny that was great but
a quick second place to that one facts
are your friends simple conversations
about complex topics all right so the
other day i was being interviewed on a
guy's podcast guy was awesome real
hospitable we're having a good time and
he was like a like like a like a
guy
and
in my new book i have a a
line
or a paragraph where i'm talking about
i don't think gen z i don't think
millennials
are this dysfunctional weak lazy group
of people
i don't think that they are cowards or
somehow inherently deficient or broken
and he said during the interview
like there's this perception right
they're just weaker and softer and if we
could just get back to the old days
and he said you don't really believe
that do you
like i know you wrote that your book but
you don't really think that do you
i thought about the jinzy years that i
know and i thought about the millennials
that i know and i said yeah i absolutely
believe that and he's like come on man
seriously look around
and i get where he's coming from and he
was looking at the data like everybody
else and he's looking at the mental
health crisis and the rise of anxiety
and the rise of depression and the rise
of loneliness and even our own
ramsay solutions research the the we did
a big research survey here on people's
mental health and shows that gen z's and
millennials are more likely to struggle
with mental health challenges in other
generations and if you take that one
step back
right look at the number of kids going
to law school the number of kids going
to med school look at the
uh obesity rates and the plummeting
physical fitness and the rise in
diabetes i mean you can point to all
these things
and say yeah see they're just sitting
around they're playing video games
they're being lazy they don't do crap uh
yeah
that's one side it's one side of it
having worked with them for the last 20
years walking alongside
thousands and thousands and thousands of
them and then being steeped in the data
and the research here's another
perspective
the moment they were born
they were told hey by the way by the
time you're like 30 the climate will
have killed us
um because all these people are screwed
up the environment so you're going to be
dead you're probably not going to have
kids
the moment they were born was in and
around 9 11
not only were they around 911 but they
have been around adults who have lost
their freaking minds
who stay glued to these little cellular
devices who are obsessed with
dramatic
sensational news stories and uh and the
rise of 24-hour news and the rise of the
murder podcast where when our regular
day doesn't suck enough let's listen to
how somebody else's life sucks even
worse
and
they've been told that they can't trust
the news their churches the government
their parents you can't even trust
yourself why because you have a
diagnosis you've got something wrong
with you
they've been the guinea pig for world
changing innovations like social media
and smart phones they've been diagnosed
with things that nobody heard of a
hundred years ago they didn't exist and
some of that's good actually some of
that we've been able to go hey that's
actually trauma this is actually
depression this is an important thing
but some of it has been
madness
some of them have just been doped up
because they can't sit in a room for
nine hours and not move
they've had
processed food shoved into their faces
since they were born
they've had p.e and movement in laughter
and play enjoy taking out of the schools
they've had athletics taken away they've
had art taken away they've had music
classes taken
away they don't go to concerts they just
stream them
because mom and dad are working two
full-time jobs plus two side hustles and
i don't have time to take you to that
we're not gonna do that
so when i look at it from that
perspective
of course they're it completely burned
out
of course they're exhausted and fried
and anxious and depressed
of course they go towards a video game
because the real world they've inherited
is on fire
literally on fire
it takes an especially strong resilient
creative and adaptable generation to
take on what the world has dumped in
their laps and yes i know my dad told me
he used to have to do nuclear weapon
drills when he was a kid
he did
because there were nukes in cuba pointed
right at he was in houston pointed right
at him
i get the world's always been bad
but there's been anchors in education
and we're gonna be all right in an
american spirit in or a whatever spirit
is there's been collective theology that
binds a group of people together and
says hey there's something bigger that
we're serving here
and this generation has none of that
all i have is caustic it's all coming
down
and so when i see a kid
in a local university when i see a high
school kid
making it work
it's incredible and when i see kids that
are strong struggling under the weight
of the nonsense my heart breaks for him
and pointing fingers that i'm calling
him lazy that's not going to help
yelling and screaming at the news not
gonna help
sitting down and saying hey i'm sorry
that we've given this to you this way
let's do something else
if you spend time with young people it's
incredible they can be extraordinary in
their vision
and their hopes and the way they think
well i guess this is how the world we've
been handed this is how we're gonna have
to make do
and so my biggest takeaway from this
whole exchange with the interviewer was
this we need to stop defining strength
as being silent stoic and working 90
hour weeks just flexing and crushing
on the flip side we need to stop
considering any sign of struggle or
dysfunction or weakness instead
maybe strength is choosing to move
forward despite the uncertainty to
grieve despite the pain to choose
healing despite the fear
i went to college and got out in the in
in
2000
in the world was my like it's all like
you can do anything
and now to graduate after two years of
having to do online back in school back
in school online online back in school
schools cancel
by the way you're just gonna be dead
from climate change anyway and plus
inflation's going to kill you and by the
way there's going to be world war 3 and
you're going to get nuked and so why
even what are you even doing whatever
you're doing go play fortnite and just
move on with your day
to graduate college in that and say no
no no i'm going to keep pushing forward
i'm going to change the world
that my friends is strength
that my friends is resilience that my
friend is saying fine
not by my hand but in my lap this is
what got dropped here
i'm gonna make do and not only am i
gonna make do i'm gonna make changes i'm
gonna make this thing better
so hear me say
stop throwing grenades at other
generations if you will
they are people like us trying to figure
it out and i'm grateful for the young
folks figuring it out and if you're a
young folk and you're stuck and you
don't know what you're doing and you
found yourself a hundred pounds
overweight or you don't like yourself or
you're in a marriage that you didn't
know you had to how you stumbled into it
reach out and have somebody for help
because there's a different way to do
this and if you're 55 or 65 or 45 or 35
and your whole identity is based on
i'm telling you it's gonna come down
stop
reach over and tell somebody i'm not
okay reach over and say hey you know
what else is cool rest
holding hands
love
compassion kindness
patience those are virtues too
that's facts are your friends today guys
simple convos about complex ideas as we
wrap up today's show
we're gonna make this one happen
everybody
it's the old classic do you even know
who wrote this
no clue
it's a legendary song
in honor of robert from san diego
[Music]
i've been working on the railroad
all the live long day i've been working
on the railroad just to pass the time
away everybody
don't you hear the whistle blowing
rise up so early in the morning
no
y'all are the worst ever i learned a
different version
yeah cool guys we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode so i
am calling to see how to reconnect with
my husband after i broke up with my
boyfriend this will be good go ahead i'm
a bit of a unicorn or so i've been told
um remarried and and it was my happily
ever after we were married about nine
years and he passed away at about the
one one and a half year mark um and so i
started dating reunited with an old
friend from high school we hit it off we
were married a little over a year and
he died